experimente mit dem higgs teilchen sind
eine riesengefahr und zwar einer
katastrophe auf der einen seite könnte
uns das zu einer ganz neuen physik
führen auf der anderen seite könnte
diese art von forschung extrem
gefährlich sein davor hatte stephen
hawking versammelt die menschheit
gewarnt denn entsprechende experimente
mit dem higgs teilchen könnten das
gesamte universum vernichten und es wird
noch beunruhigender denn auch ohne ein
solches experiment droht dem universum
eine katastrophe eine vakuum katastrophe
klicks umsatz im future hier gibt's drei
mal pro woche spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocken nur so verpasst ihr nichts los
ging's
herzlich willkommen
vor knapp zehn jahren 2012 der riesige
durchbruch nach fast 50 jahren
intensiver suche war man am
kernforschungszentrum cern bei genf
endlich fündig geworden
der nachweis des gottesteilchen dem
higgs teilchen eine sensation in der
wissenschaft für die es später sogar den
nobelpreis gab völlig zu recht denn die
higgs teilchen sind wirklich ganz
besonders sie verleihen anderen teilchen
quasi deren masse doch der bekannte
astrophysiker stephen hawking trübte die
freude noch zu lebzeiten warnte er davor
dass die weitere erforschung des lang
gesuchten teilchens verheerende folgen
haben könnte er warnte die menschheit
sogar davor dass im schlimmsten fall das
gesamte universum kollabieren könnte
ohne erkennbare vorzeichen ganz
plötzlich und unerwartet könnten solche
experimente in einer schlimmen
katastrophe enden so hocking doch
ungeachtet dieser warnung die
experimente zum higgs-teilchen gehen
weiter so hat ein forschungsteam aus tel
aviv beispielsweise den
außergewöhnlichen zerfallsprozess der
gottesteilchen im visier dieser beginnt
mit dem higgs teilchen und endet mit
einem paar elementarteilchen den
sogenannten quarks was genau wissen wir
mittlerweile über die außergewöhnlichen
teilchen und können solche große
experimente tatsächlich zum kollaps des
universums führen was ist an den
alarmierenden warnung von stephen
hawking dran
die antworten auf diese spannenden
fragen und noch viel mehr gibt es jetzt
hier bei pixum zeit sind schon 1964
hatte der schotte peter hacks diese
teilchen theoretisch vorhergesagt
demnach ist das universum mit einer art
quanten sirup gefüllt dem higgs fällt in
dieser quanten sirup brems die teilchen
die durch ihn hindurch fliegen diese
gewinnen an masse je stärker ein
teilchen auf das feld reagiert umso mehr
masse hat es salopp formuliert man kann
es sich so vorstellen dass wenn wir
einen gegenstand hier eine zitrone in
der hand halten und wir ihn damit gegen
die gravitation nach oben drücken und
damit gegen das eichsfeld drücken der
nachweis der higgs-teilchen 2012 am cern
galt dann auch als beweis des higgs
feldes das allgegenwärtig ist und fast
allen teilchen eine masse verleiht das
higgs boson wird deswegen manchmal auch
als teilchen gottes bezeichnet peter
higgs und sein team hatten die teilchen
scherzhaft so genannt weil sie ihrer
theorie zufolge das universum erst zu
dem machen was es ist denn dieses feld
ist damit die grundlage von allem ohne
dass hitzfeld gäbe es keine gravitation
damit könnten sich keine planeten sterne
monde bilden alles wäre quasi nur ein
teilchen breit die allgemeine
relativitätstheorie würde nicht
funktionieren nur weil photonen also
lichtteilchen sich mit einer definierten
geschwindigkeit bewegen und mit dem
hitzfeld interagieren also durch die
gravitation angezogen werden wird die
raumzeit verzerrt so stark dass sogar
schwarze löcher entstehen an alldem ist
dass hitzfeld entscheidend beteiligt
doch das große problem das
higgs-teilchen lässt sich nicht lange
beobachten denn sofort nach seiner
erzeugung zerfällt es in andere teilchen
und nur diese zerfallsprodukte können
nachgewiesen werden es handelt sich also
um mühevolle detektivarbeit die
eigenschaften des higgs teilchens zu
rekonstruiert doch die arbeit wird
höchstwahrscheinlich nicht umsonst sein
und fachleute weltweit setzen große
hoffnung in die higgs teilchen
möglicherweise eröffnen uns diese sogar
die entdeckung einer neuen physik
jenseits des heute geltenden
standardmodells der teilchenphysik dazu
der wissenschaftler hat elsen vom cern
mit unseren experimenten kommen wir dem
wesen des teilchens immer näher dem
teilchen das auch als portal zu einer
neuen physik geht zahlreiche fragen sind
trotz intensiver forschung noch offen
zum beispiel warum elementarteilchen
eben die masse haben die sie haben vor
allem mit hilfe des
teilchenbeschleunigers large hadron
collider kurz lhc am europäischen
kernforschungszentrum cern ist man auf
der suche nach antworten in bezug auf
energie und häufigkeit der
teilchenkollisionen gilt der lhc als der
leistungsstärkste beschleuniger der welt
bei extrem hohen geschwindigkeiten
werden paare von protonen dazu gebracht
mit einander zu kollidieren die
ergebnisse dieser kollision werden durch
detektoren beobachtet und erfasst und
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
können daraus spannende erkenntnisse
ziehen denn jeder prozess hat quasi eine
eigene signatur im detektor doch um
seltene geschehnisse zu beobachten
müssen große mengen an daten gesammelt
werden durch die kollision von protonen
kann ein higgs boson hervorgebracht
werden doch dazu braucht es viel energie
ein beschleuniger dazu kommt sofort nach
seiner entstehung zerfällt es wieder in
leichtere teilchen ein israelisches
forschungsteam hat genau diese prozesse
genauer ins visier genommen dazu einer
der beteiligten physiker geico ran es
ist interessant zu untersuchen in
welchen teilchen und mit welcher
geschwindigkeit das higgs zerfällt um
diese fragen zu beantworten arbeitet
unsere gruppe daran die rate des
zerfalls in die sogenannten jailbreaks
zu erforschen doch das ist alles andere
als einfach denn es gibt gleich mehrere
herausforderungen zu überwinden
zum einen handelt es sich um sehr
seltene phänomene lediglich eine von
milliarden kollision hat explosionen als
ergebnis dazu kommt nur drei der higgs
teilchen die entstanden sind zerfallen
dann in die parks auf die es die
israelischen fachleute abgesehen haben
die suche wird durch ein weiteres
hindernis erschwert den fünf andere
arten von quarks hinterlassen ähnliche
signaturen in den direktoren der
gewünschte prozess ist also nicht nur
sehr selten sondern auch noch super
schwer zu identifizieren
die suche nach der nadel im heuhaufen
also nur dass diese deutlich einfacher
zu finden ist und so ist das
forschungsteam aus tel aviv bisher noch
nicht in der lage gewesen genügend
zerfallsprozesse aus allen kollisionen
zu sammeln um die rate des prozesses
genau zu dokumentieren
fest steht aber eine rate die höher ist
als die die angenommen wird wäre ein
hinweis auf ein neues physikalisches
gesetz heißt also dass das
standardmodell der elementarteilchen
ausgeweitet werden müsse doch noch ist
es zu früh für solche aussagen und die
fachleute sind diesem geheimnis weiter
auf der spur doch können und solche
große experimente tatsächlich in gefahr
bringen so wie es einst stephen hawking
befürchtet hatte er hatte bereits vor
einem jahr vor dem untergang des
universums gewarnt verursacht genau
durch solche experimente mit ex teilchen
konkret warnte der astrophysiker davor
dass das gottesteilchen unter extremen
stressbedingungen einen katastrophalen
vakuum zerfall bewirken könnte in einem
artikel spekulierte er damals über das
universum das higgs potenzial hat die
beunruhigende eigenschaft bei energien
über 100 milliarden gigaelektronenvolt
möglicherweise meter stabil zu werden
das könnte bedeuten dass das universum
einen katastrophalen vakuum zerfall
erleben könnte wobei eine blase des
echten vakuums sich mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit ausdehnt das könnte
jederzeit geschehen und wir würden es
nicht kommen sehen so mahnt der also zur
vorsicht da auf einem sehr hohen
energieniveau ansonsten ein kollaps von
raum und zeit durch das higgs boson
entstehen könnte und das ganz ohne
vorankündigung doch hawking selbst hatte
seinerzeit seiner warnung schon etwas
eingegrenzt denn ein
teilchenbeschleuniger der solche extrem
hohen energielevel erreichen könnte sei
demnach in der nahen zukunft nicht zu
realisieren und auch andere fachleute
betonen immer wieder dass am
teilchenbeschleuniger wie der large
hadron collider lhc solche probleme
nicht verursachen kann die energie sei
einfach viel zu gering somit steht also
fest kein teilchenbeschleuniger dieser
welt kann bisher ein proton oder einen
atomkern auf den wert von 100 milliarden
elektronenvolt beschleunigen eine anlage
die dazu fähig wäre müsste größer als
die erde sein dennoch gibt es natürliche
prozesse im universum die solche enormen
energien erzeugen können dabei war schon
die entdeckung des gottes teilchens ein
kleiner dämpfer für stephen hawking das
als kleiner fun fact am rande denn er
hatte mit der entdeckung des neuen
elementarteilchen seine wette verloren
kurz nach der entdeckung des higgs
bosons im jahr 2012 hatte hawking in
einem interview mit der bbc gesagt mir
scheint ich habe gerade 100 dollar
verloren er hat er wohl in der
vergangenheit mit kollegen in den usa
gewettet dass dieses teilchen wie
gefunden würde dennoch hat die
entdeckung des higgs bosons der
astrophysik hinweise darauf gegeben dass
das universum instabil sein könnte die
masse des higgs bosons liegt in einem
bereich der das vakuum instabil macht
und damit das universum insgesamt
demnach könnte sich das universum am
rande der stabilität befinden doch ein
ende droht uns nicht unbedingt in
absehbarer zeit erst in einigen
milliarden jahren könnte ein zweites
universum entstehen das sehr schnell
wächst und dann den uns bekannten kosmos
zerstört in verschiedenen modellen wird
bereits seit vielen jahren davon
ausgegangen dass unser universum zwar
langlebig aber nicht unbedingt völlig
stabil sein könnte hier geht es vor
allem um den sogenannten vakuum zustand
und damit gemeint ist der zustand des
leeren raums möglicherweise gibt es
parallel zum jetzigen zustand einen
wahren vakuum zustand mit noch
niedrigerer energie und so könnte ein
phasenübergang des kosmos drohen das ist
ein grundprinzip der quantenmechanik
demnach neigen zustände hoher energie
dazu in zustände niedriger energie
überzugehen unter fachleuten der physik
spricht man hier von der vakuum
katastrophe doch grund sich sorgen zu
machen gibt es nicht denn das ganze
phänomen wird wenn es denn überhaupt
stattfindet in sehr ferner zukunft
stattfinden da sich mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit ausbreiten würde es
selbst wenn es schon begonnen hätte noch
jahrmilliarden dauern bis es uns
erreicht hätte der kleinste
teilchenbeschleuniger der welt
revolutioniert er die wissenschaft
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
abonnieren geht übrigens auch hier oder
mit dem abo button unter jedem video
kostet nichts und macht schlau bis dann
bleibt dran